[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily britney spears's
father speaks out ahead of a
conservatorship hearing
he claims he's trying to protect her
from self-serving people
plus fashion mogul peter nygaard accused
of sex trafficking
why he's being called the canadian
jeffrey epstein and
new body cam video released in the mod
arborete case
you're a pacifier coming through not
necessarily what the defendants had to
say
immediately after the shooting later a
family rescued from their submerging
vehicle
the bystander who was being called a
hero
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
pop star's britney spears's father is
speaking out over the ongoing battle of
her conservatorship
britney spears has had a court-appointed
conservatory since 2008
following personal issues her father
james spears was named a co-conservator
along with an attorney the attorney
stepped down last year and spears now
says she's afraid of her father
a judge declined to remove him but added
a private trust
he's speaking out ahead of another
hearing in the case telling cnn
that he loves his daughter and has
stepped up for the last 12 years
to care and protect her the pop star's
attorney called her a high functioning
conservative
a term psychologist and law and crime
expert dr john de la torre
explains the idea that someone can be a
high
functioning goes completely against the
idea of
gravely disabled one of the criteria
that you need in order to have
a conservator so i can see where the
public is asking for
a free brittany issue though i'm not
sure if she's able to think her way out
of
these kinds of complicated issues and
perhaps she just needs
someone on her team to help her manage
her life
a little bit better but not necessarily
in a legal setting
joining me now is former federal
prosecutor gene rossi along with terry
austin
terry does anything you've heard so far
in this britney spears saga really
change
how this conservative short
conservatorship sorry may actually be
executed
no it doesn't you know i think the
father is actually doing a little public
relations here i think he's trying to
get
out in front of the camera but for
whatever reason
the court is thinking that britney needs
to stay
in a conservatorship and it seems to me
that she is doing just fine she's
handling
her case you know she's handling her
her music business as best as anyone can
expect so i'm a little surprised
that she is still in a conservatorship
now gene i know it's difficult because a
lot of the information in these hearings
are secret we're not able to actually
look into it but where do you see this
conservatorship going
based on what you're seeing so far well
it started around 2008 and it's
continuing to today
so there's probably something in the
record sealed
that is in the hands or minds of the of
the court
that causes the court to pause on
whether she should get her life back
financially
because when you have a conservative
ship that's a very
extreme measure if you will the person
about whom the conservatorship is
established is not able to handle their
affairs
so there's something in the record that
we don't know about that has kept this
thing going for 12 years
exactly and in other celebrity news a
judge has ordered the ex-wife of singer
phil collins to stop her scandal's
allegations in their bitter court battle
collins is suing orianne bates saying
she's refused to vacate their miami
beach mansion
bates is countersuing claiming she's
entitled to half of the property
which is on the market for 40 million
dollars her attorneys wrote in a motion
that collins developed a drinking
problem
stopped showering and became a hermit
the judge ordered her to stop her claims
or risk losing her half of the mansion
she's agreed to move out in january
federal authorities in manhattan
announced the arrest of canadian fashion
mogul peter nygaard
nygard is facing charges of sex
trafficking racketeering
and transporting minors for prostitution
prosecutors say nygard
sexually assaulted dozens of girls over
several decades
he's accused of targeting economically
disadvantaged females
and using his connections to create a
network to victimize women
the fbi raided his times square offices
earlier this year
after 10 women filed a lawsuit claiming
he assaulted them
the lawsuit now has up to 57 women
terry these allegations are so similar
to jeffrey epstein he's being labeled
the canadian jeffrey epstein
the name seems to fit eh i do think it
seems to fit brian
you know he's being charged with these
sex trafficking crimes
and the fact that he is in a position of
power just like
epstein and he's taking advantage of
young girls who
don't have positions of power i think
that is the part that is
very similar to epstein now gene you
know how the feds go after someone
especially as a former prosecutor
how hard are they going to go after
nygard and can you break down
what that prosecution will look like
well i love basketball it's going to be
a ucla full-court press
i read the press release in the articles
on this they have three
super prosecutors on this case normally
have one or two
and they mean business it's the southern
district of new york
and they probably could have i'm
guessing uh wiretaps a bunch of search
warrants
of uh emails uh residences
i i suspect they have a pretty strong
case
yeah i mean strong enough for him to be
extradited in to the estates from canada
will keep tabs on that case
still ahead on law and crime daily final
arguments in the motion for a new trial
of a father convicted of murdering his
son
but first body cam video shows the
moments after the ahmad arborist
shooting in georgia
we break down one of the defendant's
statements after the break
newly released police body cam video in
the ahmad arbory case
shows key moments after the shooting
death in february
gregory and travis mcmichael are facing
nine charges including
malus murder for the shooting death of a
mod arbory in february
investigators say gregory mcmichael
started chasing aubrey
as he left a construction site son
travis mcmichael is accused of firing
the shots
a third man william rhodey brian is
charged with boxing our
armory inn while filming the incident
he's denied participating in the killing
but his statements to glenn county
police say otherwise
right you know so i hollered at him i
said y'all got him
and he just kept running he was full boy
running down
burford um they got down to the end down
there somewhere i must have passed him
because i pulled out
of my driveway was going to try to block
him but he was going all around it and i
made a few moves at him
you know um and he
he didn't stop and they started coming
from that way
okay they is in this white truck yeah
and i
tried to kind of block him again i
didn't really know who that was at the
time but
um i tried to block him again that
didn't happen they went around me so i
turned around come back
he's out the truck on the driver's side
and he had the shotgun
okay who did the driver's side the the
driver of the truck at the start right
travis he never really raised his gun to
him okay
but about that time he come over and
started just welding on his face the
black dude started hitting the white guy
in the face
and travis really can't get away from
him can't pull up
okay with the shotgun um i think travis
even gets a
lick or two in okay and the other black
guy gets another lick or two in
and about that time the shotgun gets
raised up and he pulls the trigger
and it seems like it goes for a second
of struggling again
okay i mean like good 10 seconds maybe
okay before again
i think i heard three shots
the officer went on to ask brian if the
victim ahmad arbury was defending
himself
was he defending himself yeah
i mean if the guy will stop you know i
mean find out what was going on
i mean this would have never happened
you know
should we been chasing him i don't know
i mean but uh yeah no at that point he
was
he one time when i cornered him up over
here
he was trying to get my truck he tried
to get in my door
okay so that was on his road here no it
was on that road that road so he did he
came out your door and was pulling your
door handle on the driver's side
matter of fact so let me ask you this
what
you know what did it look like he was
trying to do he was trying to get he was
trying to get on this side of the car
right what did it look like he was
trying to do what
yeah i mean i'd cut him off pretty good
now you know but
i mean he actually pulled your hand i
won't be surprised if that's his works
right there okay he's trying to get the
handle okay
i mean there are so many parts in that
video but let's just
cherry pick two of them terry was he
defending himself
yeah and then himself himself brody
saying
should we have been chasing him i mean
what does his video do for this case in
your eyes
you know this video absolutely is
evidence that the fact that they were
cornering him and blocking him
and chasing him of course ahmad aubry
was defending himself
he was trying to save his life so this
part of the video is very different from
the very end of the video
because it shows that he was being
chased down he was literally being
hunted so it's an admission and i'm you
know hoping that
it is the fact that really changes
everything in this case now gina i want
to break down the video some more but
i've got to ask as a former prosecutor
this video seems damning especially what
was was heard in it
why is this the first time we're hearing
what this defendant said and not
earlier this would have painted a much
better picture for everyone
well i think the police are trying to
protect themselves here
what strikes me the most armand arbari
is dead
and three guys chased them one filmed
them
and the way the police officers are
treating these suspects
it is it's like it's like they did
nothing wrong
the guy said that mr berry ryan said
that mr arberry was
probably defending himself and we
probably shouldn't have chased him
those are two red flags and loud gongs
it's what terry just said
they chased them down and i can't i just
it
it shows to me it this shows to me
that the color of a person's skin
at times depends on how focused the
police are gonna be
if this were a white victim and there
were three black guys that chased the
white guy
and took his life i don't think those
officers
would be using the same tone of voice i
mean do you not go further
it's not that i think it's what i know
based on my practice here the fact that
they were still not arrested
weeks after saying those comments he was
defending himself
and should we even chasing him blows my
mind as to how this
rolled out but we're going to continue
to follow that case as it unfolds
coming up on law and crime daily a
harrowing rescue of a family
from their submerging car the video you
don't want to miss
plus could foul play be behind the
disappearance of a three-year-old boy in
ohio
the search for nilo continues
[Music]
the search continues for a missing
three-year-old boy whose mother was
found
stabbed to death in cincinnati angela
libby tells us why police
are losing hope that the boy will be
found alive
three-year-old nilo lattimore was last
seen on december
4th eight days later his mother's body
was found
we are concerned greatly for his
whereabouts
we want the public to know we are doing
everything as a police department
to locate nalo police say naitisha
lattimore was stabbed to death with an
unknown edged weapon her body was found
near a bridge over the ohio river
a stroller lattimore used for nilo was
found nearby
lattimore's boyfriend deshawn brown is
charged with murdering her
volunteer search and recovery groups
spent a day looking for any sign of nilo
along
21 miles of the riverbanks police say
they're very concerned for nilo's safety
we are still looking for nato lattimore
to date
please understand that but growing
concern
has risen through our investigation and
interviewing of
deshawn brown who has been charged with
the death
of nantesia lattimore growing concern to
the point we feel
that this may this event with nylo may
involve
foul play so we're asking anyone with
information whatsoever to come forward
a judge set desean brown's bail at one
million dollars and he could face more
charges after this case goes to the
grand jury
for law and crime daily i'm angelette
levy
thanks anjanet our hopes remain strong
that now it was found
the trial for a former florida mayor
charged with attempted murder
has been delayed yet again dale massad
is accused of firing at pasco county
sheriff's deputy
who served him a search warrant last
february he's also charged with
practicing medicine without a license
mossad had been scheduled to go to trial
in january but kovan 19 concerns have
pushed it back
i can tell you your honor that we have
not completely
opened up the idea of negotiating with
the state of florida
mr mccabe's office we do have to um
iron one other thing out with mr
bartlett
but my understanding is that pasco is
closed down
as far as setting trials this may be a
two-week trial
so we probably should take it off the
calendar
and in orlando police body cam video
captured officers rescuing a family from
a submerged vehicle
a man was driving thursday night with
his two sons in a car
when an animal bolted out into the
roadway the father swerved
crossed over a median and drove into a
retention pond
a witness rushed over to help the family
the bystander held the four-year-old
boy's head
above water as he called 9-1-1 officers
arrived after the 12-year-old boy
escaped the wreckage
i need you to come to me the fire
department's gonna go get your brother
and your daddy okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
hey buddy were the keys in the ignition
officers and firefighters were able to
pull the father
and four-year-old out of the vehicle the
family was taken to the hospital with
non-life-threatening injuries
when we come back a motion for a new
trial wraps up
why a father convicted of murdering his
son by leaving him in a hot car
wants a second chance in front of the
court next
[Music]
closing arguments wrapped up a hearing
for a georgia father convicted of
killing his son
by leaving him in a hot car justin ross
harris
was sentenced to life in prison without
parole for murdering his son
22 month old cooper a jury found him
guilty
but harris now wants a new trial he says
his
trial attorney failed to adequately
represent him by not calling a
particular memory expert
the expert's notes included references
to harris's online searches
allegedly for life without a child his
new defense team wrapped up their case
by arguing that those notes
should not have been taken by the state
our position is there's really there's
no legal basis to turn this material
over
um and uh we don't think
it was been contended throughout in the
trial level and it's being contented now
that there's really no legal basis for
them to have it
at that time um so the story
um the uh
state does their own in-camera and i
think it's kind of
ironic perhaps but it looks like the way
the evidence is
presented when dr diamond says that he
had the handwritten notes when he went
with the first interview
and that's the one it looks like from my
recollection of
the testimony that he um
talked to mr boring about then that
what actually the original emotions
compel for was the handwritten notes
that's what the state of georgia never
according to the trial team they never
saw that and uh
instead they got to what really was the
work product
i don't think it matters i don't think
they should go to neither one of them
but they got the work product and that
was what took
boring i told the core that's not what
he wanted
um and it doesn't matter i mean you know
either one
they had uh or what they were intent
which one they wanted to get
doesn't matter they got work product and
it was it was improper and that was
devastating to the defense
the prosecution responded by taking on
the credibility of the defense's memory
expert
witness doctor david diamond
maddox kilgore testified that he went up
to dr david diamond afterwards and said
the reason we're not putting
you on the stand is you could be
subjected to cross-examination
especially about these things um you
know
where there's inconsistencies and
testimony between your testimony and dr
brewer
with the state could go ahead and object
to your testimony especially when you're
testifying well i
interviewed some other woman who did
this one time and therefore that means
ross harris did it
that's completely not allowed and of
course the state would have objected to
that
he gave a number of other reasons to dr
diamond
for not calling him to the stand those
are the real reasons
not the fact that the state had their
hands on
dr diamond's notes not at all
so your honor our position here number
one is the court was completely correct
under the statute 1716-4
in compelling this defense to provide
the state with what the state was
entitled to
the defense is not allowed to put up a
witness who opines
here's my opinion and it's based on what
the defendant told me
without telling the state what it is
that the defendant told the expert
that's the basis of his opinion
the judge will not make a ruling about
the motion for a new trial until
mid-january terry i'm looking at this
argument about the whole dr diamond
thing what do you think is it a flawless
argument or
do you think there's a few cracks in how
that's going to be playing out
well i don't think that really should
make a difference i think that the
defense had a right to determine whether
or not dr diamond was
needed in the trial and i don't think
that that was
low performance or it was unreasonable
and so i
definitely don't think that ineffective
council is going to win the day
at the end of the day so we'll see what
happens and gene similar question is
this ineffective a sense of
assistance of counsel or they just chose
a different tactic that the defendant
didn't like
i think it's the latter uh change uh
picking a certain trial
trial tactic or strategy if it's
objectively reasonable even though you
didn't pick the best one
but you had an alternative that arguably
was was pretty good
that does not rise to ineffective
assistance to council
they chose not to call dr dimon there
was a strategic reason for not doing it
it was reasonable i think this uh motion
to vacate the conviction will fail
yeah it's going to be interesting gene
terry thank you all so much and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you